EU economics and finance ministers have
underlined their determination to agree
on key parts of the banking union with
the European Parliament before elections
to the assembly in May top of the
priority list is negotiations on the
single resolution mechanism which would
help out any European bank or credit
institution in trouble and avoid
financial shocks I were open to discuss
with the Parliament everything the Greek
presidency is fully committed to have a
mutual understanding and provide a legal
basis which is very safe for every
member state to proceed to this very
important step which is which is in
banking Union the talks with Parliament
are moving in parallel with the
intergovernmental process on a single
resolution fund a pool of national
resolution funds that could be used to
recapitalize a bank Greece chairing the
first echofon council of its presidency
says that the next two echofon meetings
will be crucial to clinching an
agreement on the single resolution
mechanism during their talks in brussels
the ministers also noted the excessive
government deficit in the newest EU
member state Croatia and recommended
measures to bring it back into line by
2016